je suppose que vous maintenez votre
plainte un peu mon neveu
ça c'est bon ça qu'à moi on va donner en
train de prendre mes bouteilles de ça
c'est mon caddie vous avez les
bouteilles qui sont là c'est un mois
bref c'est pas marqué depuis moi
j'avais pas vu moi vous avez l'habitude
non sinon
parce que je sais pas aussi ça fait deux
ans que je cherche mais est passé aux
rayons de facto non mais ça fait une
heure fut perdu ici je préfère faire mes
courses dans le panier des gens ça va
plus vite ah bah vous n'êtes pas culotté
vous
vous n'êtes pas tout et vous voici
pourtant
avait voilà c'est pour ça bon merci je
prends de ça je vais prendre les eux
aussi en attendant les et eilat a plus
qu à un autre alors que
elles sont pas très très cuite et ses
baguettes ici je trouve moi je trouve ça
c'est à moi ça sera moi ça mais vous
l'avez pas paye encore extrêmement bas
alors de chercher pourquoi j'irai le
chercher leur canada devant moi je
ramasse on ne dit pas vous ne suis pas
marqué dessus
mais là aussi c'est moi qui le prends
donc c'est pareil où est votre course en
prenant mon caddie ton copain à pourquoi
pas d'accord à temps à vous partez
d'abord je me fâche la barre et bougez
pas
[Musique]
je prends tu le sais déjà tous qui a
voulu que je vous dise vous allez tout
là bas
n'ont rien et arrêter de m'appeler ma
chérie parce que ça
c'est pas un rayon
quoique à dix bayon le rayon il avoue
même saab selon
ses commandes du cher et fouillé mon
caddie bonbons magiques eh ben mon vieux
que c'est pas votre site vous l'avez pas
payées on commet alors une alerte ou pas
je te remonter console entre elles je
voudrais pas vous demander
quel est l'esprit ouvert mais vous devez
permet le bonheur ou non exactement
[Musique]